and way to welcome to this video play PP
con and T place but against the other
cards right a3 okay let's see what he
does here 95 is critical no this is not
bad right but it's not the most critical
continuation okay
oh I'm sorry yeah very simple approach
an but you will have some issues with
the e5 pawn so night g6 looking one we
should be for us already a little bit
uncomfortable I can also play each 65
it's ok let's do this first
[Music]
okay we should be full
yes just be annoying look doesn't have
all that many great squares so here I
will get another tempo with Bishop c5
cannot just develop the knight at the
moment it's nice
now pulley yeah here I just recognized
that this also has Bishop g5 2f for
[Music]
mechanics that loses a pawn at least I
can also go Knight a for now and then to
d3 hundreds so quite unpleasant
even though rookie 3 doesn't seem to
lose outright so bad as it looks but it
doesn't seem to be he has to go to e3
otherwise icon 93 that would be an
immediate loss oops
huh isn't that's bad
what am I looking here this is hanging
this is hanging and there is 95 also
know that should be fine I have had the
capture in 93
no I should lose some material really
how does it how does white save this
okay about chica droop chicks 93m
it's not that decisive really if I go
maybe just swoop the ADA intending to
take on detour and probably I've could
have done something better here and it
looks okay but it feels like I've missed
something I have let's see the ship
takes you to is pretty annoying I mean
he has a hard time to move the night as
some p3 is hanging okay so if I play
this where do you go now
I may be look III is again playable here
the tactics don't do that not sure like
getting this but
I mean if it looks weird I know but now
then look these three you should now
cannot move
[Music]
hmm something I should have seen really
ok so it can move
[Music]
96 isn't good either whoo
yet I really miss played that bad layer
completely that isn't even clear here
dispersion check and it was there was
definitely great for black very strange
I don't know what they overlooked him I
mean I still like this somewhat but it's
not like white is falling apart and
that's probably what should have
happened
[Music]
[Music]
I need to get rid of this this ringing
piece down and yeah B should be 70 plays
hi morning
he plays Bishop d6 and okay this is this
is not great but maybe it's okay Jib g6t
care Bishop f7 and that chick here this
is prolly not so bad check and it's not
what I wanted but I might have enough
clay here
[Music]
don't know what I what I did wrong here
really if done something really stupid
the position was fantastic really for
black check and yeah I know you place
plays excellently well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I'm still going down
[Music]
check check check check
[Music]
from the channel check check and you
have to offer the drawer walk I have to
offer the drawer okay
come on Tyrell is repetition anyway I
press the call button oh now that was
the fall sick yeah I didn't dare win
this I mean the clothes really close to
just losing the jangling stuff I
probably tried around too much this is
kind of weird I mean okay it's all
Bishop f4 I thought that it would look
this but I felt like as they should be
more already yeah 93 look everything
also can had this one and then take and
then I thought that that was the thing M
and T I'm winning the house okay I was
stupid and now things are arguing that
clear amazing this good L it looks but
it isn't totally winning or anything hey
Bishop assembles was better
okay okay normal evening some some
trouble here yeah this isn't rejection I
thought I thought this was actually I
thought that that wasn't all that bad
but he just pushes the airport yeah and
then I should probably lose okay somehow
I didn't
there are wings for white butter kay was
down on the clock so I could have won
one of those early poems called early on
now this line is interesting and this is
actually okay this is actually a mistake
the angelus really are not evaluating
this so correctly I mean you can play
that for white without like losing but
it's an opulent struggle that it's not
we're here correct evaluation I'm sorry
the pawn on d5 is just not not good and
white doesn't really yeah benefit much
from the bishop our visual h5 actually
makes sense they're trying to just be
able to take this if need be and play a
forward this is a comfortable position
for black okay guys thanks for watching